.
>> Jesse: I'M SURE YOU ALL SAW
THE SUPER BOWL, CLOSE GAME,
TALENTED YOUNG QUARTERBACK DOWN
TO THE LAST DRIVE.
IN THE END THERE COULD ONLY BE
ONE CHAMP SO CONGRATS TO THE
L.A. RAMS FOR LIFTING THE
LOMBARDI TROPHY.
LIKE ALL GAMES, IT WASN'T
WITHOUT A LITTLE CONTROVERSY.
THERE WAS A MISSED PASS
INTERFERENCE CALL ON THE BENGALS
BIG TOUCHDOWN TO START THE
SECOND HALF, MAYBE.
DID THEY CALL A TIKI TACH PASS
INTERFERENCE ON THE BENGALS TO
SET UP THE LAST RAMS TOUCHDOWN?
PREBLE.
THESE THINGS CAN GO EITHER WAY,
BUT THEY USUALLY EVEN OUT IN THE
END.
THE OFFICIALS HAD A GOOD GAME.
THEY LET THEM PLAY, WHICH ISN'T
ALWAYS THE CASE.
>> THAT'S A MISCONDUCT.
THAT'S A WARNING.
>> THAT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
COME ON.
>> WE ARE SWEATING LIKE GREASE
MONKEYS OUT HERE.
>> Jesse: WHAT HAPPENS IF THE
REFUSES DON'T THROW FLAGS ON ONE
TEAM.
WHAT IF THEY ONLY PENALIZE THE
BENGALS WHILE THE RAMS MARCH UP
AND DOWN THE FIELD, EVEN WORSE,
WHAT IF THE RAMS PART ARE IN
EVIDENCE UP WITH ONE OF THE
TEAMS.
SEEMS TOTALLY UNFAIR, RIGHT?
THAT'S CERTAINLY WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE 2016 ELECTION.
THE REVS OF OUR POLITICAL
SYSTEM, THE MEDIA, THE FBI AND
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY NOT ONLY
FAILED TO KEEP HILLARY CLINTON
IN CHECK THEY CAN A NATIONWIDE
TOGETHER.
COUNTRY STILL DEALING WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES.
HILLARY REFUSED TO ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF THE ELECTION.
>> TRUMP KNOWS HE IS AN
ILLEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
I DO THINK THAT HE KNOWS THAT HE
IS ILLEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> BECAUSE OF THAT.
>> HE IS.
>> HE IS VERY INSECURE ABOUT IT.
LOOK WHAT HE IS TRYING TO DO
NOW.
PART OF THE UKRAINE SCANDAL THAT
IS SLOWLY COMING TO LIGHT IS HE
IS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
SAY NO, NO, IT WASN'T THE
RUSSIANS EVEN THOUGH OUR
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY AND
EVERYONE WHO HAS LOOKED AT THIS
SAID YEAH, YEAH, IT WAS THE
RUSSIANS.
HE IS TRYING TO SAY NO SOMEHOW
IT WAS OBAMA-HILLARY, WHOEVER.
>> Jesse: HILLARY HAS BEEN
UNABLE TO MOVE ON, NOW WE KNOW
WHY.
SHE IS JUST STICKING WITH HER
STORY.
YOU CAN'T CHANGE AN ALIBI.
THIS WEEKEND, SPECIAL COUNSEL
JOHN DURHAM DROPPED A BOMBSHELL
REPORT.
THEY DON'T CALL HER CROOKED FOR
NOTHING.
DURHAM'S TEAM FILED IN COURT.
AND IF THERE WAS EVER ANY DOUBT
THAT CLINTON WAS BEHIND THE
RUSSIA HOAX, THAT'S OFFICIALLY
GONE.
DURHAM'S DOCUMENT SHOW THAT
HILLARY CLINTON HIRED PEOPLE
OWHO HACKED INTO TRUMP'S HOME
AND OFFICE COMPUTERS.
BEFORE AND DURING HIS
PRESIDENCY.
AND PLANTED EVIDENCE THAT HE
COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA.
YEAH.
YOU HEARD THAT RIGHT.
HILLARY BROKE INTO A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE'S
COMPUTER SERVER AND A SITTING
PRESIDENT'S COMPUTER SERVER,
SPYING ON THEM.
THERE, HER HACKERS PLANTED
EVIDENCE, FABRICATED EVIDENCE
CONNECTING TRUMP TO RUSSIA.
THIN FED THAT TO THE MEDIA.
HER OWN EMAIL SCANDAL.
THEN WHEN TRUMP BEAT HER SHE
USED THIS HOAX AS AN EXCUSE FOR
LOSING.
THIS LAUNCHED A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION AIMED AT TAKING
DOWN A SITTING PRESIDENT.
HILLARY CLINTON BROKE THE LAW TO
FRAME TRUMP AS A RUSSIAN TRADER.
THE MEDIA, THE SO-CALLED UMPIRES
OF OUR DEMOCRACY WENT ALONG WITH
THE FRAME JOB.
FOR YEARS, THEY BACKED UP
WHATEVER LIES HILLARY WAS
SPEWING ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS A RUSSIAN
OPERATIVE.
>> IT THIS CLOUD OF RUSSIA
COLLUSION WILL HANG OVER HIM
WHEREVER HE STANDS.
>> IT DOES LOOK LIKE HE IS
LISTEN TO PUTIN MORE THAN
AMERICAN INTELLIGENCE.
>> ABOUT TO FIND OUT IF THE NEW
PRESIDENT OF OUR COUNTRY IS
GOING TO DO WHAT RUSSIA WANTS.
>> THES ABOUT IS BASICALLY A
RUSSIAN OP.
>> Jesse: WHETHER SOME REAL
INFORMATION CAME TO LIGHT LIKE
THE FACT THAT THE STEELE DOSSIER
WAS AS PHONY AS MY EIGHTH GRADE
GIRLFRIEND WHO SUPPOSEDLY WENT
TO ANOTHER SCHOOL, THEY DOUBLED
DOWN ON THEIR DENIAL.
AND THEY TRASHED JOHN DURHAM'S
INVESTIGATION INTO THEIR OWN
LIES.
LISTEN.
>> THE BIGGEST SCANDAL WAS WHEN
THEY SPIED ON MY CAMPAIGN.
>> THERE NO REAL EVIDENCE OF
THAT.
>> OF COURSE THERE IS.
IT'S ALL OVER THE PLACE.
>> NO.
>> LESLIE, IN SPITE OF MY
CAMPAIGN AND THEY CALLED --
>> -- DONALD TRUMP AND WILLIAM
BARR PROMISED DURHAM WOULD
EXPOSE HUGE CORRUPTION BUT HE
HASN'T DONE THAT.
>> APPARENTLY ONGOING CONCERTED
REPUBLICAN AND PRO-TRUMP PROJECT
TO TRY TO TURN THE INVESTIGATION
OF THE RUSSIA SCANDAL INTO SOME
KIND OF SCANDAL ITSELF.
>> OH, NO, OKAY.
WAIT UNTIL THE DURHAM REPORT
COMES OUT AND THEN NOTHING
HAPPENS AND THEY MOVE ONTO THE
NEXT CONSPIRACY THEORY.
>> Jesse: THE MEDIA FAILED TO
POLICE HILLARY THE DIRTY COP OF
POLITICIAN AS SHE PUSHED AN
INSURRECTION.
THE LEFT LOVES TO MEMORIALIZE
JANUARY 6TH AS AN ATTACK ON OUR
DEMOCRACY.
BUT IF THAT'S TRUE.
THEN WHAT'S THIS?
THE RUSSIA HOAX AND THE THREE
YEAR MUELLER INVESTIGATION DID
MORE TO UNDERMINE FAITH IN OUR
DEMOCRACY THAN JANUARY 6TH.
LOOK AT THE IMPACT IT HAS HAD ON
OUR COUNTRY.
THE CREDIBILITY OF THE FBI AND
THE CIA SHATTEREDs, FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE NO LONGER TRUSTED.
A PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN WAS
BROKEN INTO, WAS SPIED ON.
AND WHO KNOWS HOW THE RUSSIA
HOAX AFFECTED THAT RACE.
THE 2018 ELECTION WAS INTERFERED
WITH.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION HUNG A
DARK CLOUD OVER THOSE MIDTERMS.
COSTING REPUBLICANS THE HOUSE.
THE NATION WAS GUIDE DIVIDED OUR
FOREIGN POLICY WAS AFFECTED.
IT LED TO ARGUMENTS THAT RUINED
QUITE A FEW WATTERS FAMILY
HOLIDAYS.
DURHAM'S PROBE HAS COST 10% OF
WHAT MUELLER'S HAS.
AND WITH LESS TIME AND RESOURCES
HE FOUND THE SMOKING GUN.
WAS MUELLER TRYING TO FIND
ANSWERS OR WAS HE COVERING THE
LEFT'S TRACKS?
WE KNOW THE ANSWER.
MULLER WAS A MOP-UP JOB.
AND HE WAS JUST THERE TO TEE UP
IMPEACHMENT.
ACCORDING TO DURHAM'S FILING,
THIS HACKING OF TRUMP DATES ALL
THE WAY BACK, YOU READY?
TO 2014 BELL WELL BEFORE HE CAME
DOWN THAT GOLDEN ESCALATOR.
JOHN RATCLIFFE HAS REVEALED THAT
HILLARY'S MOTIVES TO FRAME TRUMP
WERE NO SECRET.
THE CIA, FBI, THE DOJ, AND EVEN
OBAMA HIMSELF WERE BRIEFED THAT
THE RUSSIA HOAX WAS A CLINTON
DIRTY TRICK.
BUT THEY ALL WENT ALONG WITH IT,
DIDN'T THEY?
RATCLIFFE BELIEVES THAT THERE IS
MORE THAN ENOUGH EVIDENCE FOR,
QUOTE:  MULTIPLE INDICTMENTS.
IS WHO COULD BE NEXT.
ARE JAMES CLAPPER AND JOHN
BRENNAN NEXT ON THE CHOPPING
BLOCK?
THEY DID A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF
TRYING TO THROW US OFF OF
HILLARY'S TRAIL.
LISTEN HOW THEY RESPONDED WHEN
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM
BARR SAID IN CONGRESSIONAL
TESTIMONY HE BELIEVED TRUMP WAS
SPIED ON.
>> WELL, I WAS VERY DISAPPOINTED
IN WHAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
BARR SAID TODAY ABOUT SPYING.
WHEN HE WAS REFERRING TO THE
INVESTIGATION, THAT WAS
PREDICATED, CERTAINLY, AND THAT
THE FBI WAS TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHAT THE RUSSIANS WERE
DOING.
>> BOTH STUNNING AND SCARY.
I WAS AMAZED AT THAT AND RATHER
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WOULD SAY SUCH A THING
THAT YOU KNOW, THE TERM SPYING
HAS ALL KINDS OF NEGATIVE
CONNOTATIONS.
AND I HAVE TO BELIEVE HE CHOSE
THAT TERM DELIBERATELY.
>> Jesse: FEDS USUALLY CIRCLE
THE WAGON AROUND OTHER FEDS.
WHO ANIES WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
TO THOSE TWO CLOWNS.
THIS A LEVEL OF CORRUPTION NOT
SEEN IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
THIS IS MORE BRAZEN ANTHONY THAN
THE WATERGATE BREAK.
IN HILLARY'S HACKERS BROKE IN,
PLANTED EVIDENCE, THEN GOT THE
FEDS TO TRY THROWING A PRESIDENT
OUT OF OFFICE.
ISN'T IT TIME SHE FACED THE
CONSEQUENCES?
[CHANTING LOCK HER UP]
>> Jesse: HAS THE TIME FINALLY
COME?
ARE WE WITNESSING THE END OF THE
CLINTON DYNASTY?
ONE OF THE FIVE FAMILIES OF THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY, LOOKS LIKE
HILLARY PLAYED HER LAST GET OUT
OF JAIL FREE CARD WHILE BILL
FELT THE WRATH OF THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT AND LOST HIS PILOTS
WINGS FROM HIS DAYS ON JEFFREY
EPSTEIN'S LOLITA EXPRESS.
HILLARY CLINTON WAS ON THOSE
FLIGHTS?
>> NUMEROUS TIMES.
>> Jesse: ON THE FLIGHTS THAT
BILL CLINTON WAS ON WITH JEFFREY
EPSTEIN, THE STEWARDESS OR
STEWARDESSES, MANY OF THEM WERE
UNDER AGED WERE DRESSED AS CANDY
STRIPERS?
>> CORRECT.
>> AND THEY WERE.
>> 26 TIMES, I BELIEVE.
>> BACK OF THE PLANE?
>> BEDS, BEDROOM, YES?
>> Jesse: EVEN CLINTON'S PHONY
CHARITY FOUNDATION HAS BEEN
EXPOSED AS A PAY FOR PLAY
SCHEME.